this morning we are focusing on the next
step in the world of
sound which is actually a step back to a
better version of sound
technology can make a lot of things
better but that's not the case with
recorded music
the quality of which has suffered as we
move to ipods and now streaming
but there is hope as more and more
people are finding
just watch and listen
this is the most sensual fun you will
have
that will not end you up in a 12-step
program
[Music]
our journey to the unveiling of what
might be the best record player in the
world
in brooklyn new york began in an old
clothing factory
in rural pennsylvania fleetwood pa is a
lot different than
brooklyn here is where the things get
made
jonathan weiss is the founder and ceo of
oswald mills audio
and fleetwood sound
after majoring in international
relations at princeton
he pursued a career as a documentary
filmmaker until he realized his true
passion
was sound
[Music]
and set off in a quest to build the
finest sound amplification system
ever the kind of personal craftsmanship
you see here is almost unheard of
and everything is made by locals using
local products
the slates from here the woods from here
our welding shop is right over there
the people who do waterjet cutting this
is cut on a five
axis water jet machine by mennonites
you're sitting here
on a treasure trove of both materials
and
human know-how and abilities the quality
of this work is almost
as impressive as the sound it produces
[Music]
why is it needed because weiss says over
the past several decades the quality of
recorded music around the world has
entered
a very dark place the problem is that
in technology the the idea that things
get better cheaper smaller
that works with things like computers
but it doesn't work with sound
because sound waves they're our size
what we hear
is actually our size and you want to
miniaturize it
you screw it up when most of us listen
to music these days
we hear mp3s introduced in 1993
they took off with napster and became
ubiquitous
why are mp3s so bad
95 percent of the sound is gone can you
imagine watching a television set
where 95 of the pixels are dark you
wouldn't watch that at all
but your brain and your ears are so much
more sophisticated with sound
when you say somebody's we're missing 95
percent of the sound
what does that mean because people say
what do you mean the algorithms for mp3s
the reason that you can have 10
000 songs on an ipod is because 95
of these of the information in the music
is
gone it's compressed away it doesn't
come back on the other end
[Music]
that is where these giant cone-shaped
horns come in
weiss says their size and shape make
them the best way to amplify and direct
sound without any distortion the idea
isn't new
the design dates back to some of the
earliest phonographs
which required a way to amplify sound
without electricity
those original players used wax
cylinders which later evolved to vinyl
records
which many argue is the purest way to
listen to recorded music
[Music]
and people seem to be getting the
message last year for the first time
since 1986
sales of vinyl outstrips cds turntables
can cost between hundreds of dollars
or 300 000 the brand new player weiss
unveiled for us
inside his brooklyn showroom
[Music]
it's great
[Music]
it just it consumes you we're making
stuff that's really a throwback
to when sound really mattered and when
it was really the best that it ever was
for most people these days music is it's
background music
so that's tragic all these records over
here none of these artists made those
things to be background music
you hate talking about the prices i do
why
because you know we're in a culture
where price is the product
where where people go like it's a x
hundredths of thousands of dollar thing
and then
that's what it is i don't want that for
this i want people to look at this and
go like wow
that's cool looking i wonder what it
sounds like does it bug you that the
vast majority of people
will never be able to afford this i'm
working on that by the way
fleetwood sound is intended to be a
lower cost option to the oswald mills
brand
thousands of dollars for equipment
instead of hundreds of thousands of
dollars for equipment
for weiss music is a spiritual
experience
he hopes the next generation is willing
to invest in
what art is more intrinsic to
the human condition than music everyone
listens to music and makes music
everywhere
but what we've done because of our
culture
is we've reduced music to something that
is really a
just a pale shadow of what it was
what do you want your musical legacy to
be i just want people to realize what
is possible
[Music]
some of these some of these cone-shaped
horns are so powerful
if they're really turned up they can
actually put cracks in buildings really
because of the sound waves because the
sound waves are that power now normally
you don't have to do that we we didn't
do that but sitting there
in the in the showroom at oswald mills
and listening to it
it is you have to be there and you have
to experience it because it's something
else you look like you enjoyed that yeah
yeah